today on the mat wall show governments
at every level are seizing essentially
unlimited power for themselves during
this crisis should we be cooperating
with this that's the question we'll will
tackle
also five headlines including another 30
days tacked on to these shutdowns at
least another 30 days can this can the
economy actually survive that long plus
our daily cancellation and much more all
coming up all right so first of all by
the way what do you what are you guys
doing about I was thinking about this
this morning what are you doing about
hair haircuts and everything because I'm
on the verge of letting my wife cut my
hair for me because I don't know how
much longer this is gonna go on and I
was thinking and I really have no
commentary to offer on this except to
say that when you consider Herot barber
shops and salons shut down for as long
as they've been shut down on top of men
growing Quarantine beards on top of
people just not grooming themselves in
general because they feel like they're
not gonna be around anybody other than
their own family and who cares if you're
a disgusting mess around your family I
would say we are certainly at the
perhaps the hairiest point in our
history this may be our hairiest moment
at least in modern history so that's an
interesting fact just to enter into the
record books but I would be I would like
to know what everyone is doing about the
the haircutting situation that's I do
believe we should try to be
self-sufficient that's one thing though
that's difficult to be self-sufficient
with that all right now I have argued
extensively that's shutting down the
economy locking people in their homes
causing record-setting unemployment etc
these are not the right measures to take
to slow the spread of the virus we're
ruining the lives and livelihoods of
many millions people were plunging into
an economic crash unlike anything we've
ever seen before
all to accomplish something that seems
to me could be accomplished perhaps
arguably in less costly ways but there's
another aspect to these shutdowns one
that I haven't been focused on quite as
much because to me the economic fallout
is the most seems to be the most urgent
problem but this is very significant as
well of course that the government both
the federal and local level is claiming
for itself more and more power each day
that in many cases it
not actually legally possess it doesn't
have this power it's just claimed it for
itself so let me give you a few examples
of this and we'll go from least serious
to most because something that is
happening in New York City it's you know
that or might happen in New York City is
just way beyond any any kind of bounds
we'll get to that in a second but a few
examples from the past 24 to 48 hours
someone posted this picture to Twitter
we're not told where this is exactly but
it says has it come to this business is
being told to block off non-essential
items they're not allowed to sell do we
realize how dangerous this is to allow
the government to dictate what's
essential and what isn't we've seen what
they consider healthy slippery slopes
here and we see in the picture yellow
tape blocking off some of the aisles one
of them one of one of the aisles appears
to be selling blankets and pillows from
I can tell the other has toys we can't
tell what else is being blocked off now
like I said we don't know where this is
but I do I do know one place where this
is happening I'm not sure if this is if
this picture is from there or not but
according to Fox 59 officials in Howard
County Indiana have ordered essential
stores stores that are deemed essential
because they sell essential items to
stop selling items that are not
essential so they can they can be open
they can sell the essential items they
can't sell the non-essential items the
Howard County Board of Commissioners has
decreed that the following items are not
essential jewelry furniture home in long
decor toys or games carpets rugs
flooring non-emergency appliances music
books magazines crafted art supplies
paint entertainment electronics all of
those are non-essential okay now the
first problem that immediately springs
to mind here is that if you're trapped
inside especially if you have kids toys
and games and craft supplies are pretty
damned essential it seems to me they're
essential to the psychological health of
your children and your own psychological
health as a parent most importantly I
mean the kids are trapped inside they're
not allowed so in many places you can't
even take them
park you can't take him to a playground
and especially if you live in a suburban
area now fortunately we live it more out
in the country so there's plenty of
places places for them to go outside and
run around but if you don't have that
then what the hell are you kids gonna do
you can park them in front of the TV I
guess four hours at a time days on end
but it's good to have things like games
and toys and that sort of thing so the
kids have something different I would
consider that pretty essential I mean at
least it's not as essential as like
water but it's more essential than say a
lot of the snack foods that a grocery
store would sell I assume like ice cream
and cookies and that sort of thing I
assume those are still being sold right
so what's more essential for a kid
during a quarantine cookies and ice
cream or you know arts and crafts
supplies I know what he would say is
more essential to him what the young
child would say but as a parent what
would you consider to be the more
essential resources to have at your
disposal for your kids so what we've
decided that all food items or we
haven't decided this in this case this
Board of Commissioners has decided that
all food I'm fight to die tomara
seneschal but most everything aside from
that is not based on what logic how
would they come to this conclusion and
the other question of course is how does
it significantly increase the danger of
infection or have spread if I'm already
in the store and I've been walking
around the food aisles and then I stop
by on the way to the on the way the
canister I stop by in the game aisle
really quick and grab monopoly if I've
managed to navigate the food aisles
without getting sick or without
spreading a sickness to other people
then isn't it safe to assume I can
repeat that feat for another minute or
two as I go to a different aisle of the
store the thing is all those questions
are sort of irrelevant the real question
is this how does the Board of
Commissioners in a County have the
authority to decide what which
individual items are essential and which
are not and then to prohibit the items
that they have deemed in essential yes
local governments have the authority to
issue quarantines under certain
circumstances but how do they have the
authority to him
these kinds of very specific subjective
arbitrary preferences on the public so
according to them they're gonna say no
the snack food is more essential than
the boardgame that's what you okay you
say that is that is there any science
behind that is there any kind of that's
just you've just decided that you as a
person in government in very local
government have decided that why should
that matter why should you be able to
decide these kinds of things just
because there's a virus could they
actually start whittling down the food
aisle to could they say okay no even you
know you can't just go in there and buy
food with that that's too much freedom
so here are the approved food items that
you're allowed to buy and we're gonna
post police officers outside the grocery
store and when you come out we're gonna
check your bags make sure you only have
approved food ads if you have an
unapproved item it's gonna be
confiscated could they do that it seems
like yes they can now I mean legally I
would say they can't but that is a power
that we apparently are willing to give
them lawfully or not and then it raises
other questions too like if if if they
can do this because of a health crisis
like a virus well then what about in
normal times couldn't they say we have a
health crisis of obesity and heart
disease and and therefore you're
prohibited from selling if you're a
grocery store you're prohibited from
selling you know such-and-such food
items that contribute to that crisis
couldn't they say that again I would say
legally I don't see how they could but
this apparently is a power that we're
giving them or that we're going to allow
them to take where does it go from there
before we move on I want to tell you
about noon and I think this is a very
important thing as we're talking about
food and everything and especially as
people are locked down and you're not
getting as much exercise and everything
that you normally would be getting it's
even more important to be healthy you
know and that's what Noom is all about
it's all about
making healthy decisions about about
helping you adjust your lifestyle get
into healthy habits that's what I've
found to be so important about about
noon is that is the way that it helps me
form good habits because I know I get
stuck in really bad habits and I'm
struggling with that now especially I'm
snacking a lot you know because you're
bored a lot of us boredom snacking or
you know just the stuff is there you're
you've got a extra food in the house
you're trying to stay so keep keep
supplied and so you have to kind of
ration it and Noom can help with that as
well it helps it helps you understand
the psychology behind better decision
making to make you smarter and put you
in charge with moderation or restriction
you know it's not like there's good food
or bad food or off-limits food it's just
about it's just about that it's about
moderating and about having a strategy
and how you eat you know not just
jumping in diving in headfirst as I can
tend to do now you could join the noon
community pair up with a virtual coach
to plan your strategy to reach your
goals your personal coach and the noon
community are there to keep you in check
and inspire you along the way if you
crave more knowledge and news blogs and
supplementary materials are there to
satisfy your curiosity and make your
health goals even more attainable so
shut off all the noise and sign up for
your trial today at noon dot-com slash
Walsh that's n-o-o-o m.com slash Walsh
get personalized guidance at noon comm
slash Walsh that's Noom comm slash Walsh
n om comm slash Walsh
okay so meanwhile over in the UK this is
in the UK but it's still relevant if
you're in the United States a tweet from
the Warrington Police Department it says
over night six people have been
summonsed for offenses relating to the
new coronavirus legislation to protect
the public these included out for a
drive due to boredom returning from
parties multiple people from the same
household going to the shops for
non-essential items ok these are people
that have broken the new laws that a
very important law of being of not
driving out of boredom now how do they
know that people are out driving because
of boredom or because they're returning
from a party how do they know that well
I would assume it's because they're
pulling people over at random and asking
them where they're going and why I don't
know how else they could possibly know
it
and then ticketing them if the reason is
not approved by the government again
there's a million problems here just
just one that I'll point to briefly is
how does this not increase the risk of
spread you know you've got someone just
going out for a drive assuming they're
obeying all the traffic laws now if
they're not obeying the laws if they're
speeding or being reckless then give
them a ticket for that but assuming
they're obeying the laws and not putting
anybody in jeopardy they're in their car
how are they gonna spread the virus is
it gonna be like a drive-by spread
you're afraid they're gonna roll the
window down and start coughing on random
pedestrians as they drive by now even if
they did that the chances that they
would actually spread it that way seem
to be slim to none but again if they do
that somehow this is a crazed biological
terrorist try to spread the disease then
you know arrest them for that but if
they're in the car and they're going for
a drive at abort them I just don't see
how they're putting anybody at risk now
you could say well they could get into
an accident even if they're obeying all
the traffic laws is a possibility of
getting into an accident okay yeah
there's a possibility and then there's a
risk of spread there but where does that
possibility comes because it comes
because you got into an accident and now
you have to have interaction with the
police probably if it's a fender bender
or even with the maybe you end up in the
hospital but so your way of mitigating
that is to guarantee that every time
someone gets in a car now they're gonna
have an interaction with police because
you're pulling them over so the police
have to interact and the reason the
police are doing that is because if they
don't do it then there may be more
interactions with police and then it
doesn't make any sense it makes no sense
whatsoever there's no reason to do this
other than we have the power to do it
now back to the US and I think the worst
example of government overreach that
we've seen here yet this is well I'll
let him speak for himself this is Mayor
Bill de Blasio
in New York listen everyone has been
instructed that if they see worship
surfaces going services going on they
will go
to the officials of that congregation to
inform them they need to stop the
services and disperse if that does not
happen they will take additional action
up to the point of fines and potentially
closing the building permanently okay so
there you go there's a bill de blasio
but all plenty to say about that but
before we do a word from our very good
friends over at Rock Auto rockauto.com
especially these days when maybe you
can't get out of the house you don't
want to leave the house as much this is
even more reason if you have car trouble
because you still still need to have
your car functional if you have car
trouble
then rockauto.com even more now is is
the way to go with the ever-increasing
numbers of makes and models it's now
impossible to stock all the parts you
need in a traditional chain storefront
so even if you feel like going into a
traditional store and if it's open for
you to go into well it's probably not
gonna have what you need anyway so why
endure often pointless or seemingly
intimidating questioning from the people
at the desk where you're embarrassed if
he can't answer it right away and then
you have to wait while they look it up
online and then they tell you oh we got
to order that it'll come it'll be in in
X number of days or weeks right why go
through that when you have access to all
of those parts that you need in the
phone that's in your pocket just pick it
up go to rockauto.com
one reason to repair and maintain your
cars is to save money that you can then
use for other important things like your
mortgage or food there a million things
you could use it for why would you
choose to spend thirty percent fifty
percent a hundred percent more for the
exact same Auto Parts that you would get
down at the store so why would you
choose the extra hassle and the extra
money Muraki alikom is a family business
serving Auto Park customers online for
twenty years ago to rockauto.com to shop
for auto embody parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the rockauto.com catalog
is unique and remarkably easy to
navigate quickly see all the parts
available for your car or vehicle and
choose choose the brands specifications
and prices that you prefer it's an
amazing selection reliably low prices
everything you could possibly need go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck right Walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you all
right
so bill de blasio says
that if you have a Worship Center open
it'll be closed perhaps permanently he
might close it permanently as and you
could never open it again bill de blasio
thinks he has the authority to close
churches and synagogues permanently if
they don't comply with his demands by
the way notice how he signals out Church
and since churches and synagogues you
didn't hear it in that clip you can kind
of tell based on the context that that's
what he's talking about but it didn't
here in that clip but he also said quote
if you go to your synagogue if you go to
your church and attempt to hold services
after being told so often not to our
enforcement agents will have no choice
but to shut down those services I don't
say that with any joy it's the last
thing I'd like to do because I
understand how important people's faiths
are that's the old this hurts me more
than it hurts you
thing right that you hear from abusive
spouses or parents church or synagogue
he says church or synagogue what's
missing here what type of worship
building did he not mention specifically
is that isn't there another one that you
might find in New York oh you're at
mosques so so what are mosques allowed
to continue operating now de Blasio
whether we're including mosques or not
at least with churches at synagogues he
says we can close them permanently does
he have the constitutional authority to
do that can he's completely override the
First Amendment in the name of keeping
us safe can he just toss it out like it
doesn't exist no he can't and if you
were to try to do this if you were to
actually try to close down places of
worship permanently because they're not
complying with his demands well all I'll
say about that is that is that the
founding fathers would recommend armed
revolt in a case such as that and I
would not be one to argue with those
recommendations that's all I'll say now
we have to ask ourselves what do we
think this is about the government
officials who are threatening to close
down churches for ever trying to decide
what items a store can sell having
drivers pulled over and questioned
telling their citizens they can't go for
long walks outside giving them a time
limit on the amount of time they're
allowed to spend outside as the mayor of
Chicago has done and other places as
well that's happening do we think this
is all about their undying passion to
protect the public is this a is this
about them being public servants that
are really into safety and just just
have a great compassion and and a
passion for for protecting people or is
this a power trip by out of control
narcissus you even look at the the
facial expression of Bill DeBlasio as
he's talking about this you can even see
this kind of smirk on his face because
he loves this he loves being able to say
this especially someone like the Blasio
that he that he's able to get up there
and threaten to shut down churches he
loves every minute of that he's enjoying
that what we find yet again as we have
been warned as the cliche goes about
power and and how it corrupts when you
hand people basically unlimited power as
we've done during this pandemic it will
be abused it will be used for purposes
that have nothing to do with public
safety or anything like that and the
other problem is we're not going to be
able to get everything back that we gave
up that that's another thing that we've
learned the government never temporarily
seizes power that never happens it will
always retain at least a piece of the
power that it took for a quote temporary
measure and usually the most important
piece and before long people just get
used to it and don't really ask
questions anymore
or after a while if you do question it
you're seen as sort of a radical sort of
a you just think about 9/11
all the different ways that happened
just one example would be the government
decided it had the authority to set up
these these these government agents and
every in every airport and if you want
to get on an airplane now you have to
submit to whatever amount of searching
they decide they want to do up to it up
to n
including groping you and your in your
you know genital region if they decide
that's what they're gonna do now when
they when the government first started
doing this people protested and reacted
the way you would expect people to react
when the government just declares that
you know what we can do this now if you
want to get on a plane you're
essentially a suspected terrorist and
and you're you're the bill of rights is
is at least for the for the time you're
going through TSA is suspended and we
can search you and that's it even though
you're not specifically suspected of a
crime there's no reasonable suspicion
the fact that you want to get on a plane
is reason enough at first people
protested it and but now everyone's kind
of gotten used to it and they complain a
little bit but if you actually suggest
if you actually get up there as I have
and and really propose that we should
get rid of TSA and go back to allowing
the airports to do their own security
because by the way 9/11 was not really a
failure of airport security it was a
failure of government government had
many opportunities to catch these guys
before they did what they did the
government failed and because of the
government's failures the government
gets to take more power only in
government doesn't work that way you
fail and you get more power your
punishment is you get more power so but
now you know people people protest at
first didn't like it gradually they got
used to it and now we're at a point
where if you actually suggest we
shouldn't have this which is what you
know like half the country or more when
it back in when TSA was first proposed
and first initiated the majority of
people would have said no no no we can't
do it but now if you if you really
propose that we shouldn't have TSA most
people are gonna look at you like you're
some kind of crazy libertarian because
they get used to it how many things that
are happening right now are we going to
just get used to as a part of life how
many of the things that we all recognize
as dramatic seizures of power now will
we ten years from now accept as normal
and so that if someone complains about
it ten years from now they're seen as
crazy radical libertarian basically
anarchists there's a that's a very
serious question we need to we need to
ask ourselves all right before we go to
headlines if you haven't had a chance to
see some of our new content called
all-access live you should head over to
Daley wire come check it out we unveil
it a few weeks ago and it's a it's a
more norm it's a kind of more relaxed
programming style and we're sitting
there having a conversation kind of a
Q&A but I don't really like to call it a
Q&A because that makes it sound even
more formal than it is and I really
enjoyed doing it I'll be doing it again
on Wednesday 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time 5
p.m. Pacific and all you do is you come
by and in like I said it's we're all
sort of ISIL
in quarantine and this is a time for us
to have a conversation the show is
originally intended for our all-access
members but during this national
emergency and time of isolation we've
opened it up to all of our members and
in doing so accelerated the launch so
please join us let us know what you
think about it we'd love to get your
feedback and if you're around at 8 p.m.
Eastern tonight 5 p.m. Pacific
join us on all access live over at daily
wire.com
now to headlines number one to get the
economy the idea of getting the economy
up and going again by Easter is now
officially out the window it seems Trump
yesterday said that social distancing
guidelines will be extended on another
30 days but Trump also says that that's
okay because we've saved 2 million lives
already through these measures now I'm
not sure if Trump is aware of this or
not but the model that he's using to
come to that number has been
significantly modified so it's not I
don't think anyone now really seriously
says or proposes that millions of lives
are in jeopardy but either way another
30 days the problem of course is that
the economy is not gonna survive another
30 days so you could say 30 days you can
keep everything shut down for 30 days
but the economy is gonna be in ruins by
the end of it millions of small
businesses are already on a knife's edge
many of them have already gone under
they don't have the ability the
financial ability to continue on for
another month without revenue it's just
it's not an option for millions of small
businesses and we say small businesses
we're not just talking about really
small mom-and-pop type shops that have
one employee you know that's the family
member yeah we're talking about those
two but not just those we're talking
also about companies that employ dozens
of people you know there aren't many
businesses in America that have the
ability to go to zero revenue for 30
days or more really by the end of 30 to
be-what almost be over 40 days if it
even ends at that point the majority of
business the vast majority businesses in
America do not have that ability they
don't have those kinds of cash
serves laying around remember three
million people were officially put on
the unemployment rolls the first week of
the shutdowns the second week this past
week we don't have the official numbers
yet but if you look at the state numbers
you can already tell it's probably gonna
be more than three million and so we're
entering a point where every successive
week
the unemployment numbers will break the
record set by the week before it and
those are just the official unemployment
numbers we're not even talk the people
who can apply for unemployment and do
because and are actually able to get
through because unemployment websites
across the country are crashing and
shutting down the phone lines are jammed
so the people who actually successfully
apply for unemployment they're going to
be a small fraction of the total number
of people who are actually unemployed so
what will the actual unemployment number
be on April 30th there are 60 million
people 70 80 million I don't know we are
charging headfirst into a catastrophe
and it's become clear to me that as we
do this you know a lot of people don't
realize two things number one they don't
realize that the government does not
have a magic wand and so the government
can't magically just freeze the economy
in place and then come back forty days
or three months later or however long
and zap it again with the magic wand and
everything goes back to normal the
government can't do that the government
also does not have the godlike power to
resurrect something that is dead and if
the economy dies the government can't
perform a belated Easter miracle and
resurrected it's not gonna happen
because those businesses that have gone
under they're gone they don't magically
come back to life the people that have
lost jobs at the end of the shutdown
they don't magically have a job now many
of them know many of them will be able
to find other jobs not all of them
though and also we have to think about
what other jobs you know we have all
these small businesses shutting down
and a lot of people are gonna be out of
a job for a long time because they're
not to be able to find another one but
what are the companies that are still
hiring Walmart Amazon those kinds of
companies and so what we're seeing is is
these these big corporate chains that
are and maybe this has been happening
for a while of course for a long time
for decades
slowly but now in the course of a few
weeks we've seen a dramatic shift and
it's almost like the transfer
transformation is complete where these
big chains are cannibalizing permanently
a lot of these small businesses and so
when you see these numbers of and how
many people Amazon is hiring in Walmart
and people celebrate oh there's still
people being hired that is it's good
that folks are getting a job but what it
represents is a new reality for us where
you've got a handful of these big
corporate chains and they control
everything and you might say it's
already been that way well no not really
because there were still tens of
millions of small businesses in America
soon that's not gonna be the case
anymore and the second thing to keep in
mind here is that just you know a
depression is a very bleak affair it's
not I I think a lot of us we were sort
of whistling past the graveyard and we
don't realize what this is gonna mean
for us I also think there are many
people who assume that they're somehow
gonna be insulated from the reality of
an economic crash and that's probably
not think there are probably a few
people very rich people who not only
will be insulated from an economic crash
but will profit off of it that's always
going to happen you're probably not
going to be one of those people and
neither will I okay going on to the
second headline here's perhaps a preview
of one of the one of the one of the
widespread ramifications of a economic
depression in Knox County Tennessee in
the span of just 48 hours according to
the mayor there was nine suicides in
Portland the police say that suicide
related calls skyrocketed by almost 25%
in just the first week of quarantine and
these are only two local anecdotes I
think sadly we're gonna see a lot more
of this
now we already know it studies have
shown that suicide rates go up during
economic downturns and that's to be
expected but what happens when you have
not just a downturn but a full-scale
crash and what happens when that crash
occurs while people are isolated how
much more is that going to amplify the
tragic results number three lighten
things up a little bit here headline
from The Daily Beast Joe Biden launches
podcast here's the deal to provide a
voice of clarity during uncertain times
just what we need I know I was this is
what I've been waiting for to get me
through this as a Joe Biden podcast now
the only caveat here of course this is a
Joe Biden podcast so it's only going to
be available on record you can you can
play it on your record player though the
Biden camp says because they're on the
cutting edge here they say that they're
planning within five to six weeks to
roll out a cassette version of it so
that way you could sit around the record
player with your family listen to
podcast or you could pop it in the
Walkman rollerblade around town
listening to it before you get stopped
and ticketed by police number four I'm
probably gonna want to expand on this
and talk more about it in depth maybe
tomorrow but for now here's the headline
from The Washington Post says
perspective homeschooling during the
coronavirus will set back a generation
of children now will not survive
surprise you to learn that I I shall we
say do not agree with this perspective
to put it very very mildly in fact I
would say that freeing our kids from the
grasp of the government school system is
maybe the only positive thing to come of
all this but just just imagine imagine
the mentality of someone who is worried
that kids will be set back because
they're around their own families too
much they're gonna be set back because
their parents are educating them in
other words they're gonna be set back as
children because their parents are doing
what parents are supposed to do which is
teach and educate their children
number five reading from Yahoo Finance's
says it doesn't matter that the United
States surpassed China this week and
reported Koga 19 cases because those
numbers don't tell us how many
people actually became infected in
either country nor did they tell us how
fast the disease is spreading since only
a tiny portion of the population in the
United States has been tested the
numbers are almost meaningless says
Stephen Goodman a professor of
epidemiology at Stanford University
there's a huge reservoir of people who
have mild cases and would not likely
seek testing he says the rate of
increase in positive result results
reflects a mixed up combination of
increased testing rates and spread of
the virus I just want to read that
because it's important point we have to
keep going back to and the media would
like to ignore on the rare occasion that
it actually reports something like that
as Yahoo did to their credit but we need
we need to remember that that the ink
yes the diseases is spreading that's
certainly the case but we don't know how
many people had it and got over it we
don't know how many people have it just
mild with mild cases and they're staying
shut up in their house as they're being
told to do and not getting tested so on
and so forth
all right let's move on to our daily
cancellation will be canceling gwyneth
paltrow now this is from a few days ago
but it just crossed my radar actually my
wife told me about it my wife told me
about this Gwyneth Paltrow thing and
then I told my wife because she had
never heard about the infamous Paltrow
candles somehow my wife hadn't heard
about that so we swapped Gwyneth Paltrow
stories which reason is reason perhaps
to cancel us I suppose
anyway Gwyneth Paltrow is reading out
from I think this is from page six
winneth Paltrow is offering her
Instagram followers some advice while
they swell self-quarantine
Paltrow 47 shared a photo of herself
wearing gloves and a mask after a trip
to the farmers market assuring fans that
her and hubby Glee co-creator Brad
Falchuk
only removed their masks and gloves once
they neared the home and with no other
pedestrians around earlier this month
the oscar-winning actress was criticized
for a controversial selfie posted her
goop Instagram account
featuring the star donning a pricy
outfit many view the post as being
tone-deaf blah blah blah okay here's the
part that gets a cancel I don't care
about that the GUP founder recommends
that everyone transform in forced
isolation into an opportunity to quote
write a book learn an instrument or
language or learn to code online or draw
or paint
okay she's canceled for that because
it's advice that ignores the existence
of children and now if you're
quarantined by yourself or just with a
spouse or even with older kids I could
see maybe yeah try to do watercolor and
learn French or whatever fine not a bad
idea but I happen to be locked down with
four kids under the age of seven and so
the only language skills I'm learning
are just new and inventive ways of
saying things like be quiet go play
outside stop hitting your brother
that's a big one I guess I could learn
how to say that stuff in French maybe
that's the problem maybe my kids speak
French and that's why they don't listen
I may be that's the issue all along I
could try it
it's been good too don't get me wrong
we've we've had a lot of family time a
lot of family time a lot of family time
and my wife said the kids doing arts and
crafts and I've taught my son how to
play baseball that's been a good real
baseball not t-ball he'd been doing
t-ball before so I told him I should
taught him how to you know hit the ball
like a real baseball player and we've
we've played board games and my daughter
has discovered a passion for doing the
dishes which is great would be very nice
so she knows how to do the dishes now
and and also enjoys doing it she can
also change the baby's diaper so which
means that I'm basically tapped out on
those fronts because any time it's my
turn to do it I just say to my daughter
hey you know and she loves it she loves
doing it there's been a lot of positive
stuff happening but you can only stay
locked in a house with four kids for so
long before chaos ensues and that's the
point and in fact we've had the added
complication of the fact that we have a
toy room in our house in the basement
strategically placed so that we could
just tell the kids go play down in the
basement and and a place for them to
destroy if they want to like the mayor
of Baltimore said during the riots a few
years ago give them give the rioters
space to destroy well I have a similar
strategy with my kids we put them in the
basement go destroy that if you want the
problem is they took us a little bit too
literally on destroying it
and someone one of my kids left the
faucet on in the upstairs bathroom this
happened on Friday left the faucet on it
stayed on for two hours the drain was
clogged because one of them clogged it
too before that was kind of a team
effort and and it's it spilled over and
flooded the whole bathroom the water
dripped down into the basement it's into
the ceiling the ceiling is like caving
in now and and it went into the HVAC
system and so now we got to have bring
people out to a whole demo which is
really interfering with this with the
self isolation part of it so it's the
whole thing none of my kids will admit
will admit that that they were
responsible for this although my my son
tried to recruit my driver tried to
recruit his younger brother into taking
the fall for it because his younger
brothers three years old and my son
tried to convince my younger brother to
to to admit that he did it and I only
know that because I walked into the room
while my older son was saying to his
younger brother so you did it right
buddy you did it you said you did it you
left the faucet on didn't you do it are
you gonna tell daddy that you did it now
I know you might think well I heard my
older son saying that to my younger son
which means that my older son is one
responsible and maybe he is but I
wouldn't put it past his twin sister the
older brother's twin sister to convince
her brother to try to convince the
younger brother to take the fall because
the sister would know that I would hear
the brother trying to convince the other
brother and then think that it's his
fault you know they'd it's like that
level of manipulation is something that
my daughter is capable of at the age of
six anyway all that is just to say this
is why Gwyneth Paltrow's cancelled my
bathroom flooded and so Gwyneth Paltrow
is canceled that sums it up that's the
logic now we'll go to emails a just one
one email why I'm wrong and in fact this
represents probably about five or six
emails I got just like this from people
on the other side of the of the pond
remember you can become a daily wire
member and in that way send emails to
the the Matt Walsh oh this is from
Stephanie says dear Matt thank you for
your cancellation of the Derbyshire
police for its totalitarian
heavy-handedness towards walker's richly
deserved to add the correct sinner
source Innes
their touch and not distract us with the
comical pronunciation derbyshire please
note that the name of this county is
pronounced Darby Shearer with the
emphasis on the first syllable
Derbyshire many thanks for a good
company especially these difficult times
Derbyshire is that Derbyshire Derbyshire
Derbyshire well here's a thing Stephanie
like I said I got five or six emails
correcting me on how I pronounced
Darby's Derbyshire Derbyshire and you're
all telling me different things about
how to pronounce it unless I just don't
understand your pronunciation guides
which is possible but either way this is
America okay and in this country there
are no rules of pronunciation we just
pronounce stuff however we want and
everything is pronounced fifty different
ways depending on where you live and
that's the way things work here in
America so don't you try to tell me how
to pronounce the names of your towns
I'll pronounce it how I please
Derbyshire over there in Derbyshire
that's the pronunciation okay that's the
way we do things in our culture also
don't try to impose your truth on me
about how to pronounce things because
that's the other thing we've learned in
recent times
you know we all have our own rules of
language pronouns everything and so this
is this is my rule this is my truth
don't try to impose on me you big it but
thank you for the email and we'll leave
it there thanks I'm ready for watching
thanks for listening stay safe out there
god bless Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
25 days after President Trump said he
hopes the country will reopen again by
Easter the president changed course and
announced an extension of federal
lockdown guidelines through the end of
April we will examine the catch-22 of CO
vid 19 then the World Health
Organization continues to bungle
coronavirus but never fails to parrot
Chinese Communist Party propaganda we
will take a look at the wh o and why it
needs to go and finally New York Mayor
Bill DeBlasio threatens to shut down
churches and synagogues permanently if
they have the audacity to hold religious
services during the pandemic all that
and more check it out on the Michael
NOLA
[Music]